have you ever wondered about those
creepy one-eyed stones you know the ones
I'm talking about they're present in
several Zelda games normally they tell
you the time if you strike them with
your sword you can use a mass figure
hints and advice from them yeah those
stones throughout the games are present
in they're never given an actual
explanation as to what they are or why
they exist at all or how they're even
able to speak to link so let's try to
answer those questions in this video
[Music]
these stones which are called gossip
stones or even boying statues in one
game therein are featured in the game's
Ocarina of Time Majora's Mask Phantom
Hourglass spear tracks and Skyward Sword
in each game they serve a similar
purpose they gossip in Phantom Hourglass
they're literally described as being
quote quite the little chatterbox is end
quote in game you can see this is the
truth if you strike a gossip stone in
ocarina of time which is the first game
they were introduced in the stones will
balance or bowing around and reveal the
time of day in game after they've
finished buying game but their real
chatterbox nature comes to fruition in
ocarina of time if link speaks to a
stone while wearing the mysterious mask
of truth which unlocks more dialogue
resulting in revealed secrets and hints
about other special items or places in
game now this is all super cool and
helpful but how do they know this
information and how do they even work
here's what I think and I'll get to
explaining this in just a sec but since
I love just you know jumping ahead I'm
gonna go ahead and tell you my theories
statement I believe the gossip stones
are made of the luminous rocks we find
in breath of the wild and imbued with
the souls of dead sheikah who keep
eternal launch over the people of Hyrule
now does that sound crazy because I
realize it might but just hang in there
I'm gonna piece this together in a very
informative way firstly we know beyond a
shadow of a doubt that these stones are
related to the sheikah directly not only
did they make their in-game debut in
ocarina of time which also just so
happened to debut the first appearance
of the sheikah tribes iconic teardrop
symbol but they literally have the
sheikah teardrop slapped on the face of
every gossip stone additionally as
mentioned before if youngling completes
the mask trading sequence in ocarina of
time he can borrow the mysterious mask
of truth which is confirmed to be a
sheikah mask the happy mask salesman
himself says quote this is the mask of
truth it is a mysterious masked passed
down by the sheikah plain and simple if
link wears this mask and speaks with a
gossip stone the stone will then speak
to link about Hyrule and its inhabitants
instead of simply telling link what time
it is this confirms the stones as
essentially being Shi
technology secondly Hyrule has a dark
past that bears some major concern for
the protectors of the royal family in
the shadow temple of ocarina of time
Hyrule is stated to have a bloody
history of greed and hatred this dark
past has historically led to Wars and
even a couple demon games in there you
know normal stuff but the sheikah are
sworn allies of the royal family meaning
they protect them at all costs how do
they protect them well this tribe is
also referred to as shadow folk
preferring to operate from the shadows
out of sight and out of mind you know
like the Brotherhood from Assassin's
Creed it's a known fact about the tribe
that they prefer to work from the
shadows and with their own symbol being
an eye that never shuts I don't think
it's too far a stretch of the
imagination to imply that they
essentially set up a bunch of security
cameras all over Hyrule to keep watch on
evil and the like this is after all a
very effective strategy for information
and safety that we use all over the
place in real life today
if the sheikah had the technology why
wouldn't they
thirdly I know what you're thinking this
is cool and all but how in the world
would they make stones that do this
stuff well here's an answer for you they
don't make them they simply imbue them
in the game breath of the wild there are
tons of a certain kind of rock called
luminous stone that is seen to be
originating from the crust of Hyrule
itself luminous stones glow with the
souls of the dead according to in-game
lore so why should the stone be only
present in breath of the wild after all
rocks are among the most ancient
materials known to man if not the most
ancient I think it's very safe to say
that the luminous stones were always
present in Hyrule and are only more
apparent in breath of the wild because
the Hyrule you see and breath of the
wild is a post flood Hyrule don't
believe me check out the rock salt item
you'll see for yourself
anyway the sheikah are no strange is to
literally embarking on eternal missions
dedicated to serving hialeah and
assisting the hero just look at the
sheikah monks in breadth of the wild
they've been motionless and dormant for
at least 10,000 years is it really so
hard to believe now that some of the
sheikah who pass away or are at the end
of their lives choose to live out their
days as a watch
a remnant spirit residing in stone
serving the royal family and death I
mean what greater honor is there than
spending your entire eternity serving
your deity and assisting the chosen hero
so you may be convinced by my theory by
now because I mean why wouldn't you be
but there's one last very important
question to ask why are there none
present in breath of the wild I think
this has a simple answer personally
while it's possible that due to
calamities and such the stones were
destroyed I think they could have all
been removed from their positions when
the Highlands began to scorn the sheikah
the sheikah man named cato in breadth of
the wild tells us that the hylians
feared sheikah technology and thus the
technology was buried away in hidden
from hylians following the events of
calamity Ganon's initial appearance
10,000 years ago on the same note why
would they save the gossip stones from
the same fate I think it's possible that
the stones are still there just way way
under the ground but of course this is
all speculation what do you think are
the gossip stones the souls of dead
sheikah still buried underground or
something else hey guys thanks so much
for watching please be sure to hit that
like button if you enjoyed the content
and subscribe with that sweet sweet belt
if you haven't already for top notch
Zelda content we are so close to 10,000
subscribers once you help us hit that
going I can't wait to see what we can
accomplish together
also huge huge thank you as always to my
patreon supporters if you're interested
in getting your name featured in a video
and pre access to my content please
check the link in the description below
and check out the support tiers also
join our discord server to jump into our
growing community I believe that's all I
got for you so I hope you have a great
rest of your day peace
[Music]